[Music]
our cooking confidence coach Nanny Bobby
is back in studio thanks to Chapman
Automotive the sponsors of this segment
today we are learning how to make Ojai
pixie Tangerine setting I feel like I
gotta say that with some twang yes you
do except Ojai is in California yeah
Oxnard Oxnard Ventura area but you know
the last few times I've been here on
Wednesday since January it has been
raining every Thursday since I've been
here so every every Thursday I'll say oh
my gosh the weather outside is frightful
and it is again today but it's got to be
spring and so we're not making the
kitchen yes and Passover and Easter are
coming so we're not making something you
know warming we're we're looking forward
to 75 degrees at least okay I'm ready
for the fun so last time I was here I
talked about a tidbit which had to do
with avocados but we ran out of time so
I want to start with that these avocados
have been cut in half half they've been
sitting in a bowl of water for the last
hour and normally when you cut avocados
they turn brown but if you keep them in
this water just like this you will see
that in fact they don't turn brown and
you can keep them in water put a cover
on it for at least 10 days I've only
done it for about three or four but it
works so there's that it's a brilliant
life okay we're gonna make a salad the
oh hi pixie salad but always make your
dressing first in the bottom of the bowl
so you toss from the bottom up so we're
going to start with the notes on that
Tanger yes you always take notes I said
that just for you actually we're
starting with the Tangerine juice we're
going to put in about a quarter of a cup
of red wine vinegar I actually want to
drink that okay we're going to do some
blood orange olive oil just to add fat
Salt Fat acid and then this is my next
tidbit we're going to put honey into the
salad so let me tell you if we put the
honey into this tablespoon now what
would end up happening it would take us
until four o'clock to get it out so you
spray it with a little bit of oil either
coconut Olive or avocado put in your
honey and then watch another great oh my
God right out of there and then spray it
again okay
so there we go and here we go let's make
the salad we're gonna put in a root I
know stand back I love the arugula we're
going to put in watermelon radishes so
hold up those watermelon radishes look
at how they come in different colors
we've got 30 seconds
there we go we've got salt and pepper
sprinkle that in oh my gosh this is a
beautiful salad there we go and now
we're just gonna toss it that's it
everybody this looks like an appetizer
at a restaurant yeah this looks like a
salad out of Russia and tell me that
doesn't look like Easter with the uh
watermelon radishes and the beets Etc
it's all done finish with a little bit
of chives on top and we're all done say
bye bye there it is brilliant check out
Nanny Bubby's kitchen and Garden on
social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
again Chapman Automotive for sponsoring
this segment Ted I'll send it over to
you rock thank you so much save some of
that food for me live look outside right